i think we need to realize when we are  all plugged into machinery that makes us  angrier and angrier and angrier if it's  enraging it's engaging it will keep  people scrolling we need an attention  movement to reclaim our minds today  we're going to tackle an issue i think  we can all relate to which is our  declining ability to simply maintain our  focus and pay  attention  we have dignity we own our own minds and  we can take them back if we want to  journalist and multiple new york times  best-selling author johann hari when  confronted with his own declining  ability to focus ended up spending a  couple years going really deep into the  reasons why this was happening and the  individual and systemic solutions to  this disparating trend which is the  basis for today's exploration into the  many forces robbing us of our attention  and a look at how we might begin to  reclaim our minds and our lives